like that size like that actors prepare
for their roles months in advance of
shooting only to get to the makeup chair
and prepare some more delivering
top-notch Productions and performances
takes a lot of time effort and sometimes
pain stick around to find out what these
actors had to endure for their big
moments on screen number one These Boots
Were Made for stunts Margot Robbie tried
several different types of shoes while
modernizing the outfit of Harley Quinn
in Suicide Squad after trying some more
sensible variations she and the team
agreed that some kind of heel would work
best for the character and when they saw
the Adidas they thought they found the
right pair Margot calls them the worst
idea ever because she had to wear them
all the time Margot said anytime anyone
on set complains like this is really
hard I'm getting tired I'm like
everything you're doing I'm doing in
stilettos okay I'm doing as much as you
are all these stairs were walking up I'm
doing it in heels number two fashion
hurts Harley Margot Robbie has listed a
few parts of her Harley Quinn costume as
painful things to wear on set and among
them is something that might go
unnoticed at first the spiky gold bangle
she Sports says Harley Quinn caused some
daily wincing on set because they would
regularly stab and scratch her while she
was performing various stunts in the
action-packed role number three she
really took a plunge on this one for the
scene in Suicide Squad when Harley Quinn
dives into chemicals to bleach her skin
Margot Robbie found herself on set in a
very uncomfortable setting this could
maybe be considered the biggest
prosthetic or accessory there was on the
set Margo calls it the most unpleasant
thing she's ever done in her life saying
it was like the gluggy paint stuff that
was so far in my ears and up my nose I
was choking on it underwater and I
couldn't breathe and I tried to open my
eyes and it would glaze over my eyeballs
and I could only see white it was
horrible number four
not her usual dancing outfit cara de
Levine was asked to perform a lot of
dancing for her role as the enchantress
in Suicide Squad apparently the dance
was toned down in the Final Cut which
was a problem because she injured her
back while trying to over perform this
very stylized dance Cara also said that
the costume was made out of hard bits of
metal and stone and she was rolling
around a lot which caused Cuts all over
her body number five you might say
there's nothing natural about Aquaman
Jason Momoa might agree according to the
Aquaman actor the complicated design of
this intricate suit makes Dawning and
Doffing difficult Momoa says it's like
it's easy to pee in that but really it's
not Jason adds that when Nature Calls
you gotta be really good at holding it
we imagine that with all that running
water sound on the set of Aquaman Jason
Momoa and Amber Heard must have really
improved their holding its skills
number six
sealed for freshness Amber Heard took
one hour to get into her costume for her
role in Aquaman and not because she was
taking her time this outfit was so
intense that she couldn't even sit
between takes Amber describes the
emerald green suit as it's basically a
vacuum sealed corseted suit of armor so
right sitting was not an option to the
credit of the people who make it look so
effortless and amazing and cool it's the
exact opposite in reality number seven
it's no easy task turning into a
crocodile just ask Suicide Squad actor
anewale agbaje about his transformation
into super villain Killer Croc not only
did he have to undergo hours in the
makeup chair having claustrophobia
induced Prosthetics applied to his head
face torso and arms he also had several
hours worth of demanding physical
training to do every day even while they
were filming to build up and maintain
that Killer Croc physique fellow Suicide
Squad actor Will Smith said I think
arawale may have actually eaten a person
for real as prep for the character he
really really became a crocodile for
this movie number eight is it shark week
yet after Steve Aggie did the physical
representation of the character voiced
by Sylvester Stallone McGee had to wear
a giant strange looking helmet and a
very large foam displacement suit that
made him look more like the inside of a
shark mascot with its outer layer
removed it might have appeared silly but
Aggie knew what he signed up for Steve
Aggie wore a helmet with a frame that
was roughly mapped out where the king
shark's large triangular head would
appear but it was the displacement suit
that came as a surprise eggie estimated
that the chest piece weighed in at
around 40 pounds due to a finishing
spray that weighed a lot more than the
crew thought it would they brought it to
me like we're really sorry number nine
eye drops please actors sent hilarama
Murthy played Dr Ramsey Rosso in the
flash his Prosthetics included black
contacts which made seeing onset
difficult and his eyes itchy very
challenging when you consider that most
of his scenes require that unblinking
stare and of course the black veins on
his skin every time we see the veins on
screen we are also seeing several hours
of application and prep in the makeup
chair
number 10 need a mint this impressive
leather outfit proved to be hot and
uncomfortable for actor Teddy Sears hot
and sweaty leather wasn't the only thing
getting in the way of this actor's
stunts the full leather face mask was
restrictive to his breathing and
functioned almost like an altitude
training mask on set making any physical
activity more difficult number 11. being
smelly on set it hurts just ask the
flash actor Grant Gustin shooting a
whole season of scenes and stunts would
make any leather suit smelly in an
effort to keep things fresh production
gave Grant three flash suits to choose
from but eventually all of them smelled
just as bad okay so it might smell bad
but it looks cool right maybe so but
this suit was also very difficult to put
on so difficult that you can win
shooting only from the waist up Grant
would wear only the top half of the suit
to save time and effort number 12 glue
on glue off that's how it goes right the
flash suit collection might have grown
to be a smelly one but season one of
this series had another painful
preparation involved with day-to-day
shooting the red leather mask for the
first season of The Flash the red
leather mask we see on Grant gustin's
face had to be glued there every day
sometimes more than once and removed
when shooting was done this went on for
Nine episodes worth of shooting before
production decided to switch to a mask
with the zipper in the back instead
number 13. Jason Momoa was feeling the
sting of embarrassment when he first
tried on the earliest versions of the
Aquaman suit Jason said the First
costume is pretty terrifying it's just
basically look like it was in spandex
with gold and bright green we imagine
that the task of trusting in the process
while the costume team tries half-baked
ideas on your body must be a daunting
one while the later version looked much
better we wonder if the earlier
terrifying spandex designs that Jason
mentioned might have been more
comfortable number 14 they're
multiplying like rabbits it seems like
everyone on screen of suicide squad has
multiple tattoos for after Jay Hernandez
who plays Diablo it's like the tattoos
kept appearing he said the process was
kind of interesting it started off with
a little bit of tattoos then they
started growing it was like everywhere
my entire body was covered in tattoos
while these tattoos were not as painful
as real ones they did mean more time in
the makeup chair
number 15. hey what does your tattoo
mean with so many tattoos on screen for
Suicide Squad it's no surprise that
there might be a few stories worth
telling from set Joel Kinnaman who plays
Rick Flagg tells us how once the ink
started flowing it was hard to stop we
all ended up giving each other tattoos
it was like Harley Quinn's tattoo parlor
that's right Margot Robbie and some
other castmates found some new hobbies
as tattoo artists trading inks with each
other as they created a few mementos
from their time together on set these
actors endured some unusual occupational
hazards and while it might have been
unbearable at times we're certainly
grateful for their performances and the
Fantastical worlds they bring to life
for us to enjoy but this can't be the
whole list of uncomfortable Prosthetics
and costumes so who did we miss let us
know in the comments below
foreign